é eu venho está junto com vocês
dividindo uma experiência que foi muito
agradável pra mim é tudo o que eu sou
pela experiência que eu tive na minha
infância muito novo eu aprendi que é
trabalhar com pessoas trabalhar com a
equipe
você tinha que ter sim um dom e
paciência e saber ter a percepção de
como se fazer isso e foi lá nos anos 70
final chegando os 80 que eu comecei a
descobrir isso através de uma trabalho
que eu fui fazendo a propriedade não vou
nem falar sede plantar mandioca tem uma
renda maior e aí nesse período eu
busquei as pessoas que estavam em volta
pra me ajudar e eu também não tinha
condições de pagar e nem assim é
desenvolver um projeto nada disso é uma
coisa muito simples da roça mesmo e ali
naquele momento eu tinha uma criança que
brincava junto e eu fazia um desafio com
eles na parte da manhã fazia cova todo
da mandioca e durante o dia durante a
tarde chegava da escola
eu falava assim que eles vão fazer um
desafio vou fazer uma brincadeira vamos
ver quem é quem chegar primeiro à do
outro lado quem chegar à última mulher
do padre
isso foi uma coisa que me fez eu
entender que através da do trabalho
motivado com as pessoas mostrando para
eles que dentro desafio a gratificação
que ele tem de ganhar no sentido de se
realizar porque não foi a mulher do
padre
então é e acabaram se desenvolvendo e
fazer um melhor resultado naquele
negócio e dalin eu comecei percebendo
essa liderança que eu tinha esse formato
e aí eu comecei em outras coisas nesse
período mês depois eu trabalhei fazendo
tira leite é desenvolvido também em
aparte vendendo produtos é jazz ou
tiveram as suas matando o boi usou
segundo pescoço de boi
isso tudo eu tinha pra dentro de mim e
se aquilo que fazia com dificuldade que
tinha dificuldade eu trazia um
aprendizado para mim e me aquilo me
desenvolvi eu sabia que tinha que
insistir naquilo que plasma dificuldade
pra mim mas ao mesmo tempo sabia que ele
estaria aprendendo então esse é um
período que a gente teve assim muito que
eu tive com muito aprendizado na minha
vida e isso me desenvolveu acabei na
propriedade do meu vôo em 7
desenvolvendo isso tudo junto
i nível assim como falei antes
contabilidade para meter é rapidez
daquilo que eu faço é me deu assim
condições de uma base pareceu que eu sou
hoje
ele então assim é é eu acho que é
importante que eu acho assim que que é a
gente tem assim como é experiência no
ataque até falando é dizer o seguinte
que quanto mais a gente faz a gente
aprende
quanto mais a gente é definir aquilo bem
claro que aquilo que a gente quer deseja
fica mais fácil vai ser feito né então
nós tivemos sim é um momento que eu tive
que decidir junto com o meu pai junto
com meu irmão no nosso negócio e à parte
na vendinha e dessa venda a gente buscou
meu pai fez um desafio pra mim depois
que eu passei por isso tudo meu pai
junto comigo na propriedade foi ver
desenhando junto à mesa pidões né ele
chegou para mim e falou assim se eu
botar uma venda pra você lá e vi penas
você vai fazer esse vôo só que no
momento que eu vou ter essa venda deve
ter com ele manter minhas regra também
diz pra ir lá
no formato que hoje é tocada vendo aqui
não sai pra mim só serve sim porque ela
vendia fiado e tal eu não queria queria
vender só à vista e em dinheiro centrais
da velocidade do negócio fazer o negócio
irá eu já sabia que só tinha resultado
se eu fizesse um negócio de ir à
velocidade e aí foi feito assim que
notou à venda lá nós fizemos e condições
a venda foi um sucesso junto a seu pai
meu irmão conseguiu fazer assim juntos
no negócio da família crescer junto com
a propriedade do meu avós luta renda que
tinha foi rendendo mais um botão + outra
venda lá em casa ubá
aí ficamos três venda netão é é o o o
desafio maior foi quando assim papai
chegou pra mim e disse assim agora essa
venda você tem que tocar sozinho que eu
tive que sair de casa
eu tive que ela praticamente morando lá
que nos 20 km de distância
e assim é
ali foi um momento que eu disse agora
outro desafio para mim é sair da asa do
pai da mãe descobrir um novo negócio
descobrir novos clientes saber como
atender que novos clientes que é um
conhecido quase ninguém da região
martin que atender todo mundo bem e
atender um desafio de não vender fiado e
ele foi esse um grande desafio para mim
também
uma coisa que me colocou muito na há
como se diz na linha do desafio mesmo lá
no grau
isso foi muito bom e me desenvolveu
muito
eu tenho muita vontade de aprender e
gosta de aprender fazendo toda a minha
vida eu só por isso que eu falei antes
contei essa historinha do a sony
dificuldade que nós tivemos com tudo mas
não foi dificuldade pra mim aquilo foi
prazeroso porque eu me sentia aprendendo
me sentia valorizado porque eu aprendi
e isso no correr da minha vida eu pensei
se desenvolver pessoas a fazer trabalho
em conjunto tem que ser nessa linha e
foi uma africana diante daqueles na fama
contratando pessoas que estavam junto
folga pela melhor técnica
aquilo que eu percebi que era bom pra
mim eu dividia é do grupo
muitas pessoas e aí isso foi criando mar
liga aí foi o desafio
tudo junto né a propriedade minha avó
as venda negócio tudo tudo assim é
próximo do outro mas sim diferença de
idade de coisas mas sem fazer gestão já
em várias coisas diferentes nós ao mesmo
tempo esse foi o desafio também para mim
foi muito grande mas sempre pensando
naquilo que é o resultado em conjunto
com pessoas sempre pensando naquilo que
era bom pra mim o que é bom para o outro
sempre voltado
aquilo que eu posso fazer de melhor para
o outro ser tão bom e igualmente avião
até melhor do que eu fazer melhor é
então é assim aquele desejo de ter as
pessoas perto mas sim no sentido de que
é da comunhão daquilo que tem que ser
feito
e chegou se um momento singular desafio
né tá tudo junto
a gente tá se encolha mais voltado pra
negócio e eu meu irmão dele sim bem
garrado mesmo bem ligado mesmo porque é
assim na vida a gente tem que desenhar
os parceiros que a gente quer
os nossos desafios e nada melhor do
mundo sem fazer isso com o irmão pode
fazer um estranho a gente fala num
negócio é bom tempo estranho estudo mas
se der certo com o irmão é muito bom eu
acho que esse é um dos grandes sucessos
que a gente tem na nossa vida é a gente
preservar nossa família e ter a família
com o principal objetivo de sucesso
nos anos 80 eu já tinha sim já uma ideia
aqui porque pra mim continuar nessa
trajetória todo tem que ajeitar a minha
vida
e aí deus botou a paixão da minha vida
que tem muita importância e um passo
decisivo na minha vida que eu sabia que
eu tinha que ter alguém do meu lado na
escolha que faz parte da minha vida não
podiam decidindo que hoje eu teria essa
pessoa e amanhã
ele era a pessoa que estava escolhendo
cidade
a escolha minha foi pela forma de como é
houve uma conversa entre nós ela decidiu
em morar lá em campo novo
a mãe do meu filho
então foi ele que decide
ela tá aí eu vi esse foi um momento
assim o começo da nossa vida e hoje é
pequenininho daí esses marmanjos que
estão em questão a minha vida são as
pessoas que importa é que eu sei o que
eu sou eu pra mim eu não sei fazer mais
eu não faço nada por mim que eu não faço
proeza primeiro pra eles depois pra mim
e nesse mesmo período lá atrás eu mesmo
não tivemos que decidir avançar ou não
avançar e decidimos compramos parte do
da empresa que era do meu pai e meu pai
tinha 50% tinha cada um tinha 25 que já
tinha feito um acordo lá atrás que seria
assim
nesse momento meu pai não também não
estava querendo muito se movimentar como
a gente se movimentava achava que num
país estava bom do jeito que estava e
nós tomamos a decisão e compramos 50% da
parte dele
pagamos pagamos em um ano e meio não
pagando tudo não ficamos devendo um
centavo não 5 que papai nos cobrou mas
pela dignidade de um negócio que nós os
e família nunca tratamos família família
negócio negócio
eu falei até sócio e irmão é muito bom
quando a gente pensa dessa forma
é o nosso negócio é negócio família é
família nós não misturamos nós damos
valor ao nosso negócio para alimentar
nossa família mas não deixamos também do
negócio atrapalha nossa família é muito
é que a gente teve que tomar essa
decisão muito forte e agente tomamos a
decisão e vamos ver o que dedicam muito
mais assim
a venda que tinha a gente diz fez e
ficamos dedicar um atacado no atacado
subiu cresceu desenvolvendo eu 90
eu comprei o primeiro computador comprei
vocês sabem nem o que era um computador
mas comprei e coloquei lá dentro a
partir dali eu tive a informação que
este resultado dá resposta daquilo que
eu fazia com mais velocidade fez um
programinha tomás conseguir resultado
dia eu consegui avançar
eu sei dizer que tudo começo dos anos 90
e começo dos anos 80 usando vestido 90
90 até usando 2000
nós fizemos assim o atacado cresceu
muito chegando a um faturamento muito
bom até 97 até 97 no atacado e é muito
bem mas quando chegou em 97
a gente percebeu que o atacado não ia
tão bem com deveria ir naquilo que a
gente precisava
e aí na parte por várias foi outra
decisão neste momento tomar porque outro
mercado da forma ou outra forma de deus
cliente outra forma de entender como que
cada cliente responde a aquilo que a
gente levava pra ele produto é é é
receber o cliente dentro da loja como
tinha experiência lá de trás
isso foi difícil foi mas teve a
facilidade da minha vivência por isso
que eu falo
o aprender fazendo te dá a você uma
segurança naquilo que você vai
desenvolver aquilo que se quer
desenvolver porque se você usar aquilo
que você teve lá atrás de experiência de
vivência você alcança o objetivo que
você quer porque porque você acaba é
quem anda de bicicleta esquece nunca vai
esquecer que quem dirige carro vai
esquecer não esquece
tem coisas que você aprende que se você
colocar pra dentro é de uma forma bem em
forte mesmo aquilo que você nunca
esquecer você usa ele a todo momento
você usa ele em qualquer coisa na sua
vida então eu defendo muito a questão do
aprender desenvolver o que se aprende
mas fazendo está a fazer aquilo que você
gosta muito melhor ainda vai fazer
aquilo que você não gosta
mesmo assim fazendo mas que você
consegue o objetivo que aquilo é pra que
você está fazendo aquilo e pra quem você
consegue fazer você esquece que aquilo
que faz bank aquilo te leva aonde você
faz você faz e faz com condições de
desenvolver e agregar pessoas que eu
acho que isso pra mim não dá muito valor
eu tenho muito valor dentro quando
agrega pessoas
aquilo seja meu sonho seja objetivo e
que dar certo aquilo que deu certo é e é
isso que me move é hoje aqui na nossa
região conhece
nós hoje temos um supermercado quatro
restaurante o atacado dois mil e 800
colaboradores assim uma certeza que com
certeza porque a gente fez né não porque
as pessoas acreditam mas sim porque nós
passamos e vivemos e vivemos isso que a
melhor maneira é melhor prática de ter é
p
são aquelas pessoas que se desenvolve
tem como objetivo e desenvolve junto
tudo aquilo que a gente tem um objetivo
maior é acreditar sim eu preciso nem
precisa de muita coisa como se diz hoje
para fazer as pessoas felizes é é
atingir aquilo que as pessoas querem e
no alcance das pessoas que as pessoas
querem encontrar aquela pessoa e dar a
ela que ela que ela precisa
às vezes um chapéu a pessoa que não
gosta de chapéu e bateu no canto que a
pessoa gosta percebe que a pessoa quer
tem a percepção tem olhar a pessoa
daquilo que ela precisa ter 90 muita
coisa não seja simples
a simplicidade leva a gente é um
resultado muito mais positivo do que
aquilo que a gente quer muitas vezes
botafogo oris florescer neta
simplicidade
nós avançamos muito isso eu falo o
testemunho
nós não temos um objetivo num a nossa
equipe é toda da região nós nunca
pensamos ninguém de fora no sentido de
dizer pra ser o gerente o próximo
diretor nem nada mas temos que fazer
mudanças
a gente sabe disso mas por enquanto
ainda não mas a gente vai fazer a
mudança mas com as pessoas bem
preparadas com as pessoas sabendo que
tem de ser feito
meu propósito é sempre realizar mais e
junto com pessoas admirando pessoas
é o que mais me alegra e eu sei disso e
faz muito feliz e no e tem um momento
que me fez refletir muito sobre isso
quando o professor da arquitetura do
mundo disse morrendo de ciúme da minha
prancheta
falei mais da minha prancheta pra mim
desenhar eu quero minha prancheta para
mim desenhar e eu digo assim pra mim eu
quero morrer
falando da pessoa que ela viu seu
sorriso
então o que me faz movimenta eu saber
que as pessoas estão felizes então
alegre é um sorriso no rosto feliz e
vamos lá podemos fazer junto à rocha
assim essa foto aí é tudo que a gente
quer
aqui pra mim
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]